This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. On The Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down,
这是一档iHeart播客。保证是真人。在《Look Back at it》播客节目中。从1979年开始，这对我有重大意义。84年对我来说意义重大。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·恩格斯。每期节目，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，
and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the Outer. My Heart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
并试着去理解我们是如何撑过那段时期的。与我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊80年代。84年是个疯狂的年份。那真是个疯狂的年份。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。在Outer、我的Heart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听Look Back at it。
Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast.
嘿，大家最近怎么样？欢迎收听由你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖姆斯主持的《Learn the Hardway》。这个空间聚焦于黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都绝对不安全去进行的坦诚对话，但在这里，你是在和一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士交流。有多少男人穿着一套或者盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你不是好惹的。但这并不意味着因为你有这种能力，你就必须这样做。在AHA电台应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听Learn the Hard way。
In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in selling, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian, Michael Mancini. My mind was blown.
在2023年，单身汉明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控生下了一对双胞胎。但这场怀孕似乎是一场骗局。你伪造了这份特定的测试结果两次并进行售卖，对吗？我伪造了一次测试结果。这动用了大批互联网侦探，才揭露出一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格，一个女同性恋者，迈克尔·曼奇尼。我的脑洞大开。
I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange model.
我是斯蒂芬妮·扬。这是《爱之陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《爱之陷阱》播客。2%。当有自动扶梯可用时，选择走楼梯的人数比例只占2%。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析精神坚韧度、体能训练的科学，以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立复原力的法则。
world. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWA% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they make. for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast.
经历一些艰难困苦，你将在另一边蜕变成一个更快乐、更满足、更健康的人。在IHeartRadio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《2%》。也就是TWA%。大家好，欢迎回到《你二十岁的心理学》，在这个播客节目中，我们探讨二十岁时面临的一些重大生活变化和转变，以及它们如何塑造我们的心理。大家好。欢迎回到节目中。欢迎回到本播客。
New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. Thanks for joining us. Thanks for tuning in for another episode. Today, we are going back to the old school podcast days with a nice little chatty episode. I feel like I've been spending
新听众，老听众，无论你身处世界何地。感谢加入我们。感谢收听又一期节目。今天，我们将通过一场轻松愉快的小聊天，重回老派播客的日子。我觉得自己最近
a lot of time in the theory and the psychology recently. And we also have a few pretty heavy, like I would say, science-based episodes coming out soon, which is amazing. It's my dream job. I would do this for every minute of my life if I could and kind of break down these theories for you. But I also thought since we have so many new listeners, and it's been a while, almost a year since my last life update, I guess,
花了很多时间在理论和心理学上。而且我们很快还会推出几期相当有分量的、我想说是基于科学的节目，这太棒了。这是我梦寐以求的工作。如果可以的话，我愿意把生命的每一分钟都用来做这个，并为你剖析这些 theories（理论）。但我也在想，既然我们有这么多新听众，而且距离我上一次的生活更新已经过去一段时间了——差不多快一年了吧，我想，
that I would take today's episode to just do a bit of. of a solo therapy session for you guys and unpack all of the changes in my life recently, some new surprises and what I've been thinking about at the moment as I really transition into what feels like a completely new chapter of my life. I don't know how to explain it, but you know, those moments where, you know, at some of those seasons where everything just starts to get its glow back, like everything starts feeling a bit lighter. You kind of notice people smiling more. everything just feels a bit easier as well. Everything just feels a little bit more beautiful.
我今天的这期节目将为你们做一次有点类似于个人心理治疗的分享，剖析我生活中最近所有的变化、一些新的惊喜，以及当我真正过渡到一个感觉像是全新的人生篇章时，我目前的所思所想。我不知道该怎么解释，但你知道那些时刻，你知道那些生活中的某些阶段，一切都开始重焕光彩，比如一切都开始感觉轻松了一些。你会注意到人们笑得更多了。一切也感觉都变得更简单了一些。一切都感觉更加美妙了。
And that's kind of where I'm at right now. And it feels like it's been a long time since I've been in one of those chapters. For those of you who don't know what these episodes are, basically, it's like a solo therapy session. I kind of imagine that you guys, the audience, are like my therapist. And I'm going to give you the download and just like chat through what I've been thinking about recently. You know, it's kind of always nice to come up for a breath of friends.
而这正是我目前的状态。而且感觉我已经很久没有经历过这样的篇章了。对于那些不知道这些节目是什么的听众朋友，基本上，这就像是一场个人的心理治疗。我脑海中想象着你们，也就是听众们，就像我的治疗师。我要向你们做个汇报，然后聊聊我最近一直在思考的事情。你知道，每隔一段时间能浮出水面透口气，总是挺不错的。
air every now and again. So let's take a deep breath, take a bit of a break and just have a nice little chit chat. And then of course, we will be back Friday with another scientific psychology episode. So what I want to focus on is three things. Number one, spicy, juicy. Everyone's been asking my love life, an update on my love life. Also, if you follow me on TikTok or Instagram, yeah, I have a TikTok. It is terrible. Um, I have like the worst. content ideas, but please go and follow it to validate my attempts at trying to be a social media girl. I talked a lot about on those apps the other day about how I'm really feeling the need to move to another city or move to another country, that like restless feeling that I think is
所以让我们深吸一口气，稍微休息一下，进行一次愉快的小聊天。当然，我们周五会带着另一期科学心理学节目回归。所以我想关注的是三件事。第一点，辛辣有趣。每个人都在问我的感情生活，关于我感情生活最新进展。另外，如果你在TikTok或Instagram上关注我，是的，我确实有个TikTok。它简直糟透了。嗯，我有最烂的
quite universal for people in their 20s of needing to kind of get up a move and change everything and have those kind of spontaneous adventures. I want to talk about some of those plans, things that I've been contemplating and kind of considering for the next year of my life. And then just some general life updates. I want to update you guys on my move to Sydney, how my friendships are going, how the podcast is going, some of the behind the scenes, things, what I've been struggling with recently. And then just like a rapid fire Q&A. So a lot to get through, a lot to kind of talk about. I love doing these episodes. It feels like talking to friends, even though I'm sitting on my floor in my house, like trying to, well, praying that like a plane
内容创意，但请去关注它，以印证我试图成为一个社交媒体女孩的尝试。我前几天在那些应用上聊了很多，关于我真的很想搬到另一个城市或搬到另一个国家的感受，那种对20多岁的人来说可以说是相当普遍的、想要收拾行囊搬家、改变一切并进行那种自发冒险的躁动感。我想聊聊其中的一些计划、我一直在为自己人生的下一年深思熟虑和考虑的事情。然后是一些一般的生活更新。我想向你们更新我搬到悉尼的情况，我的友谊进展，播客的进展，一些幕后花絮，我最近一直在挣扎的事情。然后是一个快节奏的问答环节。所以有挺多内容要过，挺多事情要谈。我喜欢做这些节目。这感觉就像是在和朋友聊天，尽管我正坐在我屋里的地板上，试图——好吧，祈祷着现在不要有飞机从头上飞过。
doesn't fly over right now. So if you hear that, please forgive me. But I don't know. I think we get into it. I think that we get started, break down all the things that have been happening in my life recently. So without further ado, I say we get started. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available.
所以如果你听到了那个声音，请原谅我。但是，我不知道。我想我们这就切入正题吧。我想我们这就开始，剖析我生活中最近发生的所有事情。所以废话不多说，我提议我们开始吧。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，选择走楼梯的人数比例。
I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result. of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side,
我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析精神坚韧度、体能训练的科学，以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立复原力的法则。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等进行对话，以看透那些主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的曾认为植物油本质上会引起炎症。我们弄错了。我们在世界上感到惊慌的许多问题都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你将在另一边蜕变成
a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid surprises. And Rule 2, never mess with her friends either. We always say that trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield, and in this new season of the girlfriends, oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care, so they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh, hell no. I vowed.
一个更快乐、更满足、更健康的人。在I-Hart无线电应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《2%》。这就是T-W-O-Persent。任何男人都应该遵守两条黄金法则。规则一，绝对不要惹乡村女孩。你玩愚蠢的游戏，就会得到愚蠢的惊喜。规则二，也绝对不要惹她的朋友。我们总是说，相信你的女友们。我是安娜·辛菲尔德，在《女友们》这个新季中，天哪，这是同一个男人。一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会过。我感觉自己像是被卡车撞了。我想，这怎么会发生在我身上？警察似乎并不在意，于是她们决定自己采取行动。我说，哦，见鬼去吧。我发誓。
I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs?
我将成为他的最后一个目标。他会得到他应得的。在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《女友们》。相信我，宝贝。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯在VMA颁奖典礼上双击小肯姆的胸部吗？
Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam Jett. And I'm Alex English.
或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小肯姆到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《Look Back at it》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·杰特。我是亚历克斯·英语。
Each episode, we pick a here. unpack what went down and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack, so I'm starting to see that there's a through line.
每期节目，我们都会挑选一个年份。剖析当时发生的事情，并试着去理解我们是如何撑过那段时期的。包括最近一期邀请马克·拉蒙特·希尔的节目，大谈80年代的可卡因。澄清一下，84年对我意义重大，不仅仅是因为可卡因。我随时准备在白天谈论可卡因，但只是让你们知道。我的意思是，马克，此时此刻，这是我们第二次讨论可卡因，所以我开始看出这里有一条贯穿始终的主线。
We also have AIDS on the table right now, so. Then you're finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for. for black people. Really? Yeah. For me,
我们现在桌上还有艾滋病，所以。然后你把那句话说完。是的。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比……更重要的年份了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，
it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast,
这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听Look Back at it。欢迎收听我的新播客，
learn the hard way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations
《Learn the hard way》，我是主持人、你最喜欢的治疗师凯尔·盖姆斯。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我带来了我在心理健康领域十多年的丰富经验，以及与众多杰出嘉宾的对话。
with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the things, thing. We get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing and we're still chasing it and we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important
我说的是特里普·方丹、瑞安·克拉克。有时候，当我们追求事物、某样东西时。我们太过于沉迷于追逐的过程，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了它，却依然在追逐，并且不知道什么时候才算足够。因为人们在看记分牌。生活变成了关于胜利与失败。史蒂夫·伯恩斯，达斯汀·罗斯，因为你觉得在世期间做一个好人很重要，还是你做一个好人是因为你害怕？因为那是两个不同的意图，兄弟。绝对的。那是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你真正地做一个好人。加入我，凯尔·盖姆斯，我们在我的新播客《Learn the Hardway》中进行关于治愈、成长、父亲身份、压力和目标的真实对话。打开你免费的iHeartRadio应用，搜索Learn the Hardway，立即收听。
to be a good person while you hear on earth or are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kea, games is we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free iHeartRadio app, search Learn the Hardway, and listen now. Okay, so let's start with the juicy stuff first. So if you have been following me for a while and listening closely to the podcast, you will know that my love life over the past two years is a lot like the average 20-something year olds in that it is chaotic and sometimes a nightmare
好了，让我们先从有趣刺激的事情开始吧。如果你关注我已经有一段时间，并且一直在仔细收听这个播客，你就会知道，我过去两年的感情生活，和普通二十多岁的人很像，那就是它充满了混乱，有时简直是一场噩梦，就像过山车一样，而且绝对没有带来什么特别丰硕的成果。有时人们会说：“天哪，你怎么能直接说出我的经历？你怎么知道这就是我和这个男生、这个人或这个女孩所经历的？”我说：“因为我也正在经历这些。”因为我觉得自己好像被下了什么诅咒，或者可能只是我在收集二十多岁时的精彩故事。你知道，过去几年我一直在欣然接受这样一种观点：这是个为你的人生积攒精彩故事的好时机，好在未来你的孩子问起时你可以回答：“哦，你在爷爷或爸爸之前约会过别人吗，或者诸如此类的话？”你需要有一些这样的故事，你生活中的一些这样的人物。所以快速回顾一下，如果你是老听友，我说的是那种元老级别的节目，当时我甚至直接用iPhone在床上录音，因为以前我们就是这样做的，那时我对音频质量一无所知。
and a bit of a roller coaster and definitely has not been particularly fruitful. Sometimes people are like, oh my God, like how are you talking directly to my experience? Like, how did you know that like this is what I'm going through with this guy or with this person or this girl? And I'm like, because I'm going through that as well. Because I think that I've had some kind of curse placed on me where in Or maybe it was just like I was getting the good stories from my 20-something years. You know, I've been really embracing these past few years, the idea that this is the time to get some good stories under your belt to tell your future kids when they ask, oh, did you ever date someone before granddad or before dad or whatever? Like, you need to have some of those stories, some of those, like, characters in your life. So quick recap, if you are a long time listener, I'm talking like OG episodes where I used to record on my literal iPhone in bed because that's how we did it back in the day before I knew anything about audio quality.
但就在那时，我讲述了这档节目的起源故事。它始于一次分手，我很喜欢跟别人讲这个，因为对于一个关于我们二十多岁生活的播客来说，这绝对是一个极其典型的催化事件，分手是开启这样一个项目的巨大动力。于是我经历了那场可怕的分手，这场重大分手。我总是说我们在二十岁时有三种恋爱经历：重大分手、暧昧关系（situationship），然后最后是健康的爱。所以我先经历了第一种，从我的清单上划掉，拿了件T恤，然后继续前行，现在我发现自己对此非常感激，因为，你知道，这确实建立起了这个社群，也为我真正做自己喜欢的事情创造了机会。然后我有了那段暧昧关系的经历，老实说，我觉得人们对此会很有共鸣，但它带来的痛苦甚至超过了我的第一段真正严肃关系的结束。而且我觉得它也让我情绪上备受创伤，以至于我在约会生活中变得几乎像个野人一样。我几乎失去了对自己应该受到怎样的对待的任何标准。我只是和这一连串、一连串对我并不好的人在一起。我想这让我受了很重的伤，真的很挣扎于自己的价值感。你知道，有时有些事情是个好故事，有时有些事情是一个你本可以用更好的方式学到的教训，但你真的无法、无法收回过去，只能对它把你塑造成什么样的人心怀感激。我想现在我到了那个阶段，我对那些经历心存感激。我回首那段时光，我意识到，如果你知道那句名言，我想是出自《壁花少年》里的：我们接受我们认为自己配得上的爱。我觉得我生命中的那段时光比任何其他事情都更能证明这一点。经历与这个人的那种状况，而现在有了后见之明，能够真正清晰地看待它，并且我认为能够在没有任何强烈情绪的情况下评估这段经历，这很重要，因为它改变了我对约会的看法，以及我在一段时间内对待爱的方式——往坏的方向发展，我想可以说，但这让我得以转向以一种更健康的方式对待约会。所以在今年年初，正如你所知，我想要做一次小小的重置，真正把约会以及我的浪漫互动从我的生活中淡化，重新专注于我自己以及我真正的优先事项。而且我想当我决定这样做的时候。
But back then, I told the origin story of this show. And it began after a breakup, which I love telling people because I think for a podcast about our 20s, that is just such a quintessential kind of. catalyst event, like a breakup is such a magnificent motivative for starting a project like this. And so I went through that terrible breakup, this big breakup. I always say that we have three relationships experiences in our 20s, the big breakup, the situation ship, and then finally the healthy love. So I did that one first, checked it off my list, got the T-shirt, moved on, and now I find myself really grateful for that because, you know, it's really built this community and it's
但当时，我讲了这个节目的起源故事。它始于一次分手，我很喜欢跟别人讲这个，因为我觉得对于一个探讨我们20岁人生的播客来说，这真是一个非常典型的催化剂事件，比如分手就是开启这样一个项目极好的动力。所以，我经历了那次糟糕的分分手，那次很大的分手。我总是说我们在20岁时会有三种恋爱经历：重大分手、暧昧关系，然后才是健康的爱。所以我先经历了第一种，把它从我的清单上划掉，拿到了T恤，继续前行，现在我为此感到非常感激，因为，你知道，这确实建立了这个社群，而且它
built this opportunity for me to really do the thing that I love. And then I had this situation ship experience, which honestly, I think people can relate to this, but it almost hurt more than my first really serious relationship ending. And I think it also just left me so emotionally raw that I went so almost like feral in my dating life. I just kind of lost any sense of standard for how I deserved to be treated. And I was just with this series of series of people who were not very good for me. And I think it left me quite like wounded, really struggling with my worth. You know, sometimes things are a good story and sometimes things are a lesson that you probably could have learned a better way, but you can't really, can't really take
为我创造了做我真正热爱的事情的机会。然后我有了暧昧关系的经历，老实说，我觉得大家都能感同身受，但它带来的伤害甚至超过了我那段真正严肃的初恋结束。而且我觉得这也让我情绪上变得极其脆弱，以至于在约会生活中几乎变得有点像“野兽”一样。我几乎失去了对自己应该被如何对待的任何标准感。我只是一直和一连串对我其实并不好的人在一起。我觉得这让我伤痕累累，严重怀疑自己的价值。你知道，有时事情算是个好故事，有时事情则是一个你本可以用更好方式吸取的教训，但你真的无法收回
back the past, just have to be grateful for who it made you. And I think now I'm at that point where I am grateful for those experiences. I look back at that time and I realize that if you know that saying, I think it's from like perks of being a wallflats. we accept the love we think we deserve. I think that time in my life just really demonstrated that more than any other. I think it was just such an emotionally salient and impactful experience to me going through that situation with this person and now having the hindsight, being able to really see it clearly and I think evaluate the experience without any of the intense emotions, it was important because it changed my perspective on dating and how I approached
过去，只能对它将你塑造成为什么样的人心存感激。我想现在我已经到了那个阶段，我为那些经历感到感激。我回首那段时光，我意识到，如果你知道那句话——我想它是出自《壁花少年》——“我们接受我们自认为配得上的爱”。我觉得我生命中的那段时光比任何其他事情都更能证明这一点。我觉得经历那次与那个人的情况对我来说是一次情感上非常鲜明且影响深远经历，现在有了后见之明，能够真正清晰地看待它，并且在没有任何强烈情绪的情况下评估这段经历，这很重要，因为它改变了我对约会的看法以及我如何看待
love for some time for the worst, I would say, but then that allowed me to pivot into treating, dating in a much healthier way. So at the start of the year, as you may know, I wanted to do a bit of a reset and really de-centre dating, but also my romantic interactions from my life to just refocus on myself and what my actual priorities were. And I think when we decide to do this. When I've spoken about it before, people have often questioned whether my only motivation for this kind of activity or my only purpose or reason for doing this was because I wanted to come back and find the love of my life. Like we often, I think, sometimes think that if we take some time off from dating, that's going to really like clear the slate for something amazing
当我以前谈论过这个时，人们经常会质疑我进行这种活动的唯一动机，或者我这样做的唯一目的和原因，是不是因为我想回来寻找我一生的挚爱。就像我们经常认为的那样，有时候，如果我们花一些时间不约会，那将真正为某个奇妙的人的出现扫清道路。我懂的。我真的非常理解那种推理。我认为这非常开明，而且有点超脱，觉得如果我们真的想吸引某人，我们就必须以相反的方式行事，就像对立规律一样。但老实说，我当时根本没想这个。我只是突然意识到，从我17岁起，我的人生就一直在恋爱、坠入爱河、可能单相思某人或者心碎。在17岁到23岁之间的这段时间里，没有哪怕一次——也就是六年时间——我的生活不围绕着我的浪漫兴趣打转，我的生活没有被我不得不讲述的关于我约会过的人以及所有的狗血剧情、所有的（你知道的，也有好的方面）故事所主导，但他们总是像宇宙的中心。就像我说的，我要么因为最近的分手而彻底崩溃，要么就是疯狂地爱上某个人，因为我是个如此浪漫的人，这种事经常发生，我只是突然意识到我需要从那里面休息一下，我真的需要让自己做一段时间的主角，所以我决定今年不追求爱情，这有望a，让我重新与自己取得联系；b，也许能治愈我过去让它结痂却从未真正治愈的一些情感创伤。
to come in. And I get that. I really do understand that kind of reasoning. I think it's very like enlightened and a bit extensional to think if we really want to attract someone, we have to act in the opposite way, like the law of opposites. But truly, that was not even on my mind. I just had this realization that since I was 17, I had always either been in love, falling in love, maybe pining over someone or heartbroken. There had not been a single time between the ages of like 17 and 23. so six years where my life had not revolved around my romantic interests and my life had not been
介入。我明白这一点。我真的理解那种推理。我认为这非常开明，也带有一点延展性，觉得如果我们真的想吸引某人，我们就必须以相反的方式行事，就像对立定律一样。但说实话，这甚至不在我的脑海里。我只是突然意识到，从17岁开始，我要么一直处于恋爱中，坠入爱河，可能在苦恋某人，要么就是心碎。在17岁到23岁之间的任何时间里，都没有哪怕一次——也就是六年时间里——我的生活不是围绕着我的浪漫兴趣打转，我的生活没有被
dominated by the stories that I had to tell about the people I was dating and all the drama and all, you know, the good things as well, but there was just always like they were at the center of the universe. Like I said, I was either absolutely destroyed over a recent breakup or I was falling madly in love with someone because I am such a romantic individual that that happens quite frequently and I just kind of realized that I needed a break from that I really needed to kind of make myself the main character for a little while so I decided I would take the year off from pursuing love which would hopefully a get me back in touch with myself be maybe heal some of those emotional wounds I think I'd let scab over in the past but never truly heal
我不得不讲述的关于我约会过的人的故事、所有的戏剧性以及所有的，你知道的，美好事物所支配，只是它们总是处于宇宙的中心。就像我说的，我要么因为最近的分分手而彻底崩溃，要么就是疯狂地爱上某人，因为我是一个如此浪漫的人，这种事经常发生，我只是觉得我需要从那里面休息一下，我真的需要让自己当一会儿主角，所以我决定暂停一年不去追求爱情，希望这能：a.让我重新找回自我，b.也许能治愈我过去让其结痂却从未真正痊愈的一些情感创伤
And I think, see, just, I just wanted to embrace the joys of singlehood for some time. And I speak about this on the podcast all the time. You know, my episode, The Stigma of Being Single, is a perfect place to go if this is what interests you. But there is something really sacred and beautiful about being single. And I was really, really falling deeply into that mentality. And then, well, as the story always goes, I ended up meeting someone completely. completely unexpectedly at perhaps the most inconvenient time. Like I really, you know, I'm going to say the thing that I used to hate people saying when I was
我想，c，只是，我只是想在一段时间内拥抱单身的乐趣。我一直在播客里谈论这个。你知道，我的单身污名那期节目，如果你对这个感兴趣，是个绝佳的去处。但是单身有一种非常神圣和美好的东西。而我当时真的、真的深深地陷入了那种心态。然后，好吧，正如故事一如既往的发展，我最终在一个最意想不到的时候、在一个也许最不方便的时刻，完全出乎意料地遇到了某个人。就像我真的，你知道，我要说那句我以前单身时最讨厌别人说的话，但我真的没有在找，而且，你知道，那句俗话“当你不经意间它就会发生”。我要成为那个说这话的人。我要成为那个说我在最意想不到的时候遇到了某个人，而他们简直是最美妙、最美妙的——他简直是最棒的家伙的人。所以我要讲讲我们是怎么认识的。我不知道。我告诉过他我在做这个。我征求了他的同意。我当然不会说出他的名字，因为他有一份真正的工作，不像我。我可不想他工作的人找到这一集然后说：“哦，八卦，辛辣的八卦。”但是的，我确实告诉过他我在做这一集。所以如果你在听，嘿，我对你有好感，如果我分享过头了请让我知道。所以我们是在
single, but I really wasn't looking and, you know, that saying like it happens when you least expect it. I'm going to be that person who says that. I'm going to be the person that says I met someone when I least expected them and they are just the most wonderful, wonderful, like he's just the most wonderful guy. So I'm going to go into how we met. I don't know. I told him I was doing this. I asked his permission. I'm not going to say his name, obviously, because he has a real job, unlike me. And I don't want his people he works with finding this episode and being like, ooh, juicy, spicy tea. But yeah, I did tell him I was doing this episode. So if you're listening, hey, I got a crush on you and let me know if I overshared. But so we met on
单身，但我真的没有在寻找，而且，你知道那句话，当之最不经意时它就会发生。我将成为那个说这句话的人。我将成为那个说在最意想不到的时候遇到了某人，而他真是最棒的、最棒的人，他就是那个最棒的家伙。所以我接下来要讲讲我们是怎么认识的。我不知道。我告诉过他我在做这个。我征求了他的同意。我当然不会说出他的名字，因为他有一份真正的工作，不像我。我不想他身边的同事找到这一集然后说，哦，真带劲，真刺激的八卦。但确实，我告诉过他我在做这一集。所以如果你在听的话，嘿，我迷恋上你了，如果我分享得太多了请告诉我。所以我们是在
hinge, which I know is ironic because I speak so much about how I don't like dating apps, but here is my excuse. My excuse is that I'm a hypocrite. And then also I was in Bali at the time, and I was in Bali with some really amazing friends of mine, and two of them had just gone through like pretty terrible breakups. So, you know, when you're on your breakup holiday with like all your friends and there are all of these, like, foreign people around, all these people you're never going to see again in a beautiful, romantic, alcohol-infused city, alcohol-infused island, I guess, you're going to do what people do, which is to go on the dating apps and see if you can find, like, a little vacation lover. So I was on that trip and I was like, everyone's doing
Hinge上认识的，我知道这很讽刺，因为我说了那么多我有多不喜欢约会软件，但这是我的借口。我的借口是我是个伪君子。还有就是我当时在巴厘岛，我和一些非常棒的朋友在一起，其中两个刚经历过相当糟糕的分手。所以，你知道，当你和所有的朋友去进行分手度假，周围有所有这些外国人、所有这些你再也见不到的人，在一个美丽的、浪漫的、充满酒精的城市——充满酒精的小岛，我想，你会做人们会做的事，那就是打开约会软件，看看能不能找到一个小小的度假恋人。所以我那次旅行也在那上面，我想每个人都在这么做。我向同辈压力屈服了，下载了Hinge，我想这是我最后一次下载这个应用了。我以前做过这事。我不会再做了。我、我无法应付跟无数人匹配、漫无目的地聊上几个星期却从来不在现实生活中见面。所以我当时就在那儿，然后我和这个家伙匹配了。我们开始聊天，其实他的开场白很棒。这里给各位男士、女士、想要在约会软件上真正展开对话的人一个热门小建议：他的开场白是，听着，我真的不喜欢闲聊，我要问你10个问题，在这10个问题之后你可以决定是否还要继续和我聊天，我想那太棒了
it. I caved into the peer pressure and I downloaded Hinge and I was like, this is the last time I'm downloading this app. I have done this before. I'm not doing it again. I, I cannot deal with matching with a million people talking to them aimlessly for a couple of weeks and then never meeting them in real life. And so there I was and then I matched with this guy. And we just started talking and he had a great opener actually. Here is a hot tip for the guys, the girls, the people out there who want to actually have conversations on dating apps. his opener was listen I really don't like small talks I'm going to ask you 10 questions and after these 10 questions you can decide whether you want to keep talking to me and I was like that is great
它。我向同辈压力妥协了，我下载了Hinge，当时我想，这是我最后一次下载这个App了。我以前做过这事。我绝不再干了。我、我无法应付和无数人配对、漫无目的地和他们聊上几个星期却从不在现实生活中见面。然后我就在那儿了，接着我和这个家伙配对成功了。我们开始聊天，其实他的开场白很棒。这里有一个给各位男生、女生以及那些想要在约会软件上真正展开对话的人的实用小贴士：他的开场白是，听着，我真的不喜欢闲聊，我要问你10个问题，这10个问题问完后，你可以决定是否还要继续和我聊天，当时我就觉得，这太棒了
because it is low effort on my behalf like I have to answer the questions but like I don't really have to try and keep a conversation going and I was like let's do this like this guy is like really attractive I'm like immediately into this person let's do it so we start talking and then I'm on holiday. I kind of forget about it and I end up ghosting him accidentally. It was not like a, ugh, I don't want to talk to this person anymore. There was a lot of factors and I end up like not talking to him for like the last like couple of days of my trip. Come back home to Sydney and then I'm like, oh, whatever happened? Like, why did I not reply to that guy or did I reply to that guy? And he just didn't reply back to me. Like, let me check on this because I was really,
因为这对我来说不需要付出什么努力——我得回答问题，但其实我不需要费力去维持对话的进行，我想就这样吧，这家伙挺有吸引力的，我立刻就被这个人吸引了，那就开始吧。于是我们开始聊天，然后我在度假。我有点把这事给忘了，最后竟然意外地放了他鸽子。这并不是那种“呃，我不想再和这个人说话了”的情况。有很多因素，结果我在旅行的最后几天左右没有和他说话。回到悉尼的家，然后我想，哦，到底怎么了？就像，为什么我没有回复那个家伙，或者我回复那个家伙了吗？而他只是没有回复我。让我查一下这个，因为我真的很
enjoying our conversation. And so go back to Hinge. I've like completely been unresponsive to anyone else on the app except for this person. And I'm like, I'm really sorry for ghosting you. Here are my reasons. Do you have another question for me? Like, let's keep chatting. And he, I don't know how, but he got back to me. And he kept chatting with me. And I thank you for pulling through, bud. Like, I really appreciate the tenacity there. And we just started having like the most. amazing, like, chats. And then I was like, these questioning is, like, going on for a little bit too long.
享受我们的聊天。所以回到Hinge。我基本上对应用上的任何其他人都没有回应，除了这个人。我就说，真的很抱歉放你鸽子。这是我的理由。你还有其他问题要问我吗？我们继续聊吧。而他，我不知道怎么做到的，他回复我了。而且他继续和我聊天。兄弟，谢谢你坚持下来，我真的很感激那种韧劲。我们开始进行最棒的、
So I was like, I have a question for you. He was like, yeah, what is it? And I was like, when are you going to ask me on a date? Lo and behold, he did because I asked him to. And we went on our first date and it was incredible. It was like one of those, you know, those like four-hour dates where it's like multiple excursions. Like we got ramen and then we got drinks and then we got frozen yogurt,
最惊人的聊天。然后我想，这些提问稍微持续得有点久了。所以我想，我有个问题要问你。他问，好的，是什么？我说，你什么时候要约我出去？不出所料，他真的约了，因为我要求了。我们去约了第一次会，棒极了。就像那种，你知道的，那种持续四个小时的约会，有很多活动。比如我们吃了拉面，然后喝了饮料，然后吃了冻酸奶，
which I feel like the frozen yogurt should have come before. the alcohol, but it actually ended up working out really, really well. End of the first day, I was like, this guy, like, he's not given me the signs that he wants to see me again, which is such a bummer, but whatever, like, I'm going to go back to my single girl sleigh era because this was like a barley thing. And now we're not in Bali anymore. We're not in Bali anymore. So if this one doesn't work out, I'm going to shave my head and be single for the rest of my life.
我觉得冻酸奶应该在酒精之前吃，但实际上最后效果真的、真的很不错。第一次约会结束时，我想，这家伙，他没有表现出他想再见到我的迹象，真是太糟了，不过无所谓，我要回到我的单身女孩狂欢时代了，因为这曾经是巴厘岛的一段经历。而现在我们不在巴厘岛了。我们不再在巴厘岛了。所以如果这个不管用，我就把头发剃了，然后单身一辈子。
I genuinely thought that. I was like, if this doesn't work out, I'm just going to shave my head. I've wanted to do it for so long. and like the only thing holding me back was like male gazed and that is not a good enough reason to do it. So, and I still haven't done it. So maybe you need to rethink that philosophy. Anyhow, we have just been dating ever since. It obviously went really well.
我当时真的是这么想的。我想，如果这个不管用，我就把头剃了。我一直想这么做，唯一阻止我的是男性的凝视，而这并不是不这么做的充分理由。所以，我还没剃。所以也许你需要重新思考那个哲学。不管怎样，从那以后我们一直在约会。显然进展非常顺利。
He did want to see me again. And he has wanted to see me again and again and again. And I just, I don't know how to explain how beautiful it is to find someone, who really thinks you're amazing after so many years of dating people who I always felt like I was begging for their attention. And it was so almost, I also think something that no one talks about is how scary that can be, like how actually terrifying it can be to be like, what kind of game is this person playing here? Like, you're going to drive two hours to see me twice a week and you're going to like pay for our dates and you're going to ask me questions about myself.
他确实想再见到我。而且他想一次又一次、一次又一次地见到我。我只是，我不知道该怎么解释，在经历了多年约会那些总是让我觉得自己是在乞求他们关注的人之后，找到一个真正觉得你很棒的人是多么美好。这甚至有点，我也觉得没人谈论的一点是，这会有多可怕，就像实际上可能会令人恐惧，心想：这个人到底在玩什么把戏？比如，你愿意开车两个小时一周来看我两次，而且你还要为我们的约会买单，还要问我关于我自己的问题，
and you're going to send me flowers just because you feel like it? What are you trying to manipulate me? Like, what are you trying to get out of me here? Are you just going to leave? And it's just been this, like, kind of learning process of being like, no, this is what, like, healthy love feels like. This is what, like, healthy dating feels like. This is what it feels like when someone shows up for you and is committed to you and
而且你还要送我花，只因为你想这么做？你到底想怎么操纵我？你到底想从我这里得到什么？你是不是马上就要走了？这简直是一个学习的过程，去意识到：不，这就是健康的爱感觉起来的样子。这就是健康的约会感觉起来的样子。这就是当一个人为你出现、对你做出承诺并且始终如一时感觉起来的样子。
consistent. And I just feel so, like, safe and so happy. and I'm laughing all the time and it's just like every weekend we spend together as like someone has just sprinkled fairy dust all over those moments and all throughout those hours and I really, I don't know, I'm kind of gushing now, really fawning over this person but I don't know how I got so lucky and we were talking about this the other night and I was like, isn't it crazy that like six months ago we had no idea that this would happen? Like neither of us were really looking for a relationship, as we've since discussed. And then it just kind of fell into our
我只觉得无比安全，无比快乐。我一直在笑，真的就像每个我们一起度过的周末，就像有人在那些时刻、在那些漫长的时间里洒满了仙女尘一样，我真的，我不知道，我现在有点在滔滔不绝，真的对这个人赞不绝口，但我不知道我怎么会这么幸运。我们前几天还在谈论这个，我说：“难道不是很疯狂吗？就在六个月前，我们完全不知道会发生这种事。”我们两个人都真的没有在寻找恋爱关系，正如我们后来讨论的那样。然后它就那样落在了我们的腿上。而且感觉这个人，我仿佛已经认识他们很久了。然而他们却彻底改变了我对自己所怀有的爱。除此之外，抱歉，这只是一番深思熟虑的肺腑之言。但我认为我一直非常反感这样一种观点：和对的人谈恋爱可以具有相当的治愈效果。我以前总觉得你必须在事前做大量的工作，在进入一段关系前做大量的历史治愈和基础工作。但它却向我展示了相反的一面，对的人可以成为那最后一种成分，真正向你展示你是有价值的，并且也让生活感觉轻盈得多、美好得多，你会觉得自己是如此被感激。
laps. And it just feels like this person, I've like known them for so long. And yet they're completely changing the kind of love that I have for myself. And additionally to that, sorry, this is just like a rant of deep thoughts here. But I think I was always so in opposition to the idea that, you know, dating the right person could be quite healing. And I always kind of thought that you had to do a lot of that work beforehand, do a lot of that historical healing and groundwork before you got into a relationship. But it's kind of showing me the opposite, that the right person can be that kind of final ingredient that really shows you, that you have value, and also just makes life feel so much
融洽。而且感觉这个人，我仿佛已经认识他好久了。然而他却彻底改变了我对自己那种爱的理解。除此之外，抱歉，这只是一堆深奥想法的倾诉。但我以前总是非常反对这样一种观点，即，你知道，和对的人约会可以具有相当大的治愈作用。我总是觉得你必须在这之前做很多那类工作，在进入恋爱关系之前做好大量历史层面的治愈和基础工作。但这件事向我展示了相反的一面，对的人可以成为那种最终的调味剂，真正向你展示，你是有价值的，同时也让生活感觉如此美妙
lighter and so much more beautiful, and you just feel so appreciated. and it's just completely changed my perspective on what I deserve to the point where it's actually you know it's kind of sad when I look back at I specifically think back to this version of myself probably two years ago now yeah around two years ago who just accepted shit who just was so okay having someone like string them along I remember the like last person who I told that I loved them, I said, oh, I think I'm falling in love with you. And their response was to tell me that they were going on a date with someone else. So that's not their fault. Respect them for that. Go off king. But I stayed in that relationship or whatever you want to call it for like another two or three months.
而且它彻底改变了我对自我的看法，甚至到了这种地步——你知道，当我回想起来时，这其实挺让人难过的，我特别回想起大约两年前的这个版本的自己，是的，大约两年前，那个只会接受烂摊子、对有人这样吊着自己也觉得无所谓的自己。我记得上一个我告诉过我爱他们的人，我说：“哦，我想我开始爱上你了。”他们的回应是告诉我他们正要和别人去约会。所以这不是他们的错。为此尊重他们。干得好，国王。但我还在那段关系——或者不管你想怎么称呼它——里待了大约另外两三個月。
And I really think that I have, I hold no anger towards this person or or rage or frustration. It's just part of the story. And I think is, I think that it's so interesting now. being exposed to someone who like really does care about me and really wants to be in my life and also just ask questions about what I'm doing. So I'm just really happy. I just think about that version of myself who was crying over someone who clearly did not care about me. You know, this person who never wanted to commit who most certainly did not buy me flowers or plan wonderful weekends. And I thought that I was like so much better off alone and fully ready to spend my 20s in a bit of self-imposed solitude. And then this just kind of happened. So I hope for those of you have
我真的认为我对这个人没有任何愤怒、狂怒或沮丧。这只是故事的一部分。而且我认为现在接触到一个真正关心我、真正想融入我的生活、还会询问我在做什么的人，是如此有趣。所以我真的很高兴。我只是想起那个曾经为明显不关心我的人哭泣的自己。你知道，这个永远不想做出承诺、绝对不会给我买花或策划美好周末的人。而我曾以为自己独自一人会过得更好，完全准备好在某种自我强加的孤独中度过二十岁。然后这事就发生了。所以我希望对于那些关注我有一段时间的听众来说，这只能起到强化这样一个信念的作用：你绝对配得上一份始终如一、善良、稳定且轻松的爱，一个你不需要将就的人，一个让你觉得自己备受宠爱、有趣，而你对他也怀有所有这些感觉的人。你知道，我不想去瞎猜未来。我认为那样会破坏惊喜。所以我只想说，谁知道这段关系最终会变成什么样呢，但我确实抱有很高的期望。而重新适应生活中拥有那种浪漫力量，这成了我生活最近很大的一部分，并且这是很久以来第一次出现真正正面的浪漫力量，一个真正督促我变得更好的人。抱歉，
been following me for a while, this only serves to kind of reinforce that you do absolutely deserve a love that is consistent and kind and stable and easy, someone who you don't have to settle for, who just makes you feel adored and interesting and who you feel all of those things for back. And you know, I don't want to like try and guess the future. I think that kind of of ruins their surprise. So I will say who knows what this relationship will turn out like, but I do have high hopes. And it's just been a big part of my life recently readjusting to, you know, have that kind of romantic force in my life. And for the first time in a long time, a really positive romantic force, someone who is really pushing me to be better. Sorry, I'm not
一直关注我一段时间的朋友，这只会进一步强化这样一个观点：你绝对配得上那种稳定、善良、安稳且轻松的爱，一个不需要你将就、能让你觉得自己备受宠爱和有趣、并且你对他也怀有同样感受的人。而且你知道，我不想去瞎猜未来。我觉得那样会毁了惊喜。所以我想说，谁知道这段关系会变成什么样呢，但我确实抱有很高的期望。这只是我最近生活很大的一部分，重新适应生活中拥有那种浪漫的力量。而且在很长一段时间里，这是第一次出现真正积极的浪漫力量，一个真正督促我变得更好的人。抱歉，我不是一个
going to go on about this for much longer because I don't want to be that person whose entire reality is their boyfriend. But the final thing I've learned, I think, is that a healthy love will also challenge you in unexpected ways, especially if you have previously been with people who haven't offered you the security that this new person does. I think we often think that, like, we'll find someone who, like, really adores us and all of that past kind of hurt and trauma will disappear and will be erased from our memory. What I'm learning is that actually it is a process of sometimes being triggered by things that they do, where you're expecting a different response based on your history. So, you know, at the start of our relationship, like, he isn't a really
我不会再滔滔不绝地说这个了，因为我不想成为那种整个现实世界只有男友的人。但我想我学到的最后一点是，健康的爱也会以意想不到的方式挑战你，特别是如果你以前和那些没有提供这种新面孔所给予的安全感的人在一起过。我想我们经常认为，我们会找到一个真正崇拜我们的人，然后所有过去的伤害和创伤都会消失，从我们的记忆中被抹去。我正在学到的是，这实际上有时是一个被他们所做的事情触发的过程，根据你的历史，你会期待不同的反应。所以，你知道，在我们关系的初期，他不怎么发信息。我希望他不介意我这么说。我想他不会介意。但他不怎么发信息，现在也不是。而我是个真正喜欢在白天聊天的人。显然，我喜欢说话；我经营一个播客。所以这是顺理成章的。但我会想，他不回我的消息。他当时在工作，这是可以理解的。我就会，天哪，我会抓狂，我会想：“哦，天哪，他对我不感兴趣。游戏结束了。另一只鞋要掉了。我早就知道了。他们最后都这样。我需要完全无视他。我现在就需要删掉他的所有消息。我需要拉黑他。我再也受不了这个了。”简直就是恐慌。而我的室友会坐在我身边说：“你需要冷静下来。你需要退后一步，看清事情的本质。他对你显然很感兴趣。你们俩显然都迷恋对方。他只是在工作。这并不是他会变成你过去认识的那些人的某种隐藏信号。”所以我认为这确实是一个真正戒掉其中一些习惯的过程。但当你拥有像他这样的人时，他如此鼓励你，并真正提供那种安慰，这真的是太美好了。所以我希望这听起来不是在炫耀。我只是希望这能作为一个提醒，不要将就。如果你和一个没有这样对待你的人在一起，请认真考虑那是否是你应得的，因为我认为我学到的一点是，
big textor. I hope he doesn't mind me saying this. I don't think he will. But, like, he wasn't a, he still isn't a really big texter. And I'm someone who really likes to chat throughout the day. Like, obviously, I love talking. I run a podcast. So it comes with a territory. But I was like, he wouldn't reply to my messages. He was working understandably. And I would just, like, freak cat, I'd be like, oh my God, he's like, he's not interested in me. The game's up. The other shoe is dropping. I knew it. They all turn out like this. Like, I need to just completely ignore him. I need to like delete all of his messages right now. I need to block him. Like, I cannot do this again. And it was like panic. And my roommates would be like sitting with me being like, you need to chill
很爱发短信的人。我希望他不介意我说这个。我觉得他不会介意。但是，他以前不是一个、现在也不是一个很爱发短信的人。而我是一个真的很喜欢在一天里聊天的人。就像，很显然，我喜欢说话。我开了一个播客。所以这是工作的一部分。但我想，他不会回复我的消息。他在工作，这是可以理解的。而我就会，比如，抓狂，我会想，哦天哪，他，他对我没兴趣。游戏结束了。另一只靴子要落地了。我就知道。他们最后都这样。就像，我需要完全忽略他。我需要立刻删掉他的所有消息。我需要拉黑他。就像，我不能再经历一次了。这简直是一场恐慌。我的室友就会坐在我旁边对我说，你需要冷静
out. Like, you need to take a step back and see this clearly for what this is. He is obviously into you. You guys are obviously obsessed with each other. He is just. at work. This is not some hidden sign that he's going to turn out like any of the people that you've known in the past. And so I think that it is a process of really unlearning some of those things. But when you have someone like he is who is just so encouraging and just really offers that reassurance, it's just really beautiful. So I hope that it's not braggy. I just hope that it's a reminder to not settle. And that if you're with someone who isn't treating you like that, really contemplate whether that is what you deserve because I think something I've learned is that
一下。就像，你需要退一步，清醒地看清这到底是怎么回事。他显然对你有意思。你们俩显然都迷恋对方。他只是在工作。这并不是什么隐藏的信号，表明他会变得像你过去认识的任何人一样。所以我觉得这是一个真正改掉其中一些习惯的过程。但当你拥有像他这样的人，他如此具有鼓励性，并且真正提供这种安抚时，这种感觉真的很美好。所以我希望这听起来不像是吹嘘。我只是希望这能成为一个提醒，不要将就。如果你和一个没有这样对待你的人在一起，真的要好好考虑这是否就是你应得的，因为我觉得我学到的一点是，
there is something better out there for you and you know there is that theory in psychology around the scarcity effect like we think that like men or the people that we can date as like as a resource of running out and so we just settle for whoever's there that is so not the case you have so much time and you know the right person comes like that. along and just changes everything for you. So hold out hope, but also make good choices. Make good romantic choices. Okay, so we're going to move on from love because love is boring unless you're in it. So blah, blah, blah, blah. There's that update. The other kind of big thing that's happening in my life is I am really looking forward to a bit of a change in pace, a bit of a change in scene for a
外面有更好的东西在等着你，而且你知道，心理学中有一个关于稀缺效应的理论——我们认为男人或我们可以约会的人作为一种资源正在耗尽，所以我们就随便将就了身边的人。事实根本不是这样的。你有的是时间，而且你知道，对的人就这样出现了，然后改变了你的一切。所以保持希望，但也做出正确的选择。做出正确的浪漫选择。好了，我们要从爱情的话题移开了，因为爱情是无聊的，除非你正身处其中。所以，blah, blah, blah, blah。这就是最新的近况。我生活中正在发生另一件大事，那就是我真的很期待生活节奏和场景上的一些改变。
couple of reasons. Number one, I think I've been feeling a little bit uninspired recently, lacking a little bit of dimension. Actually, one of the episodes that I'm recording later this week is on like why this life feel boring, because I think that sometimes in our 20s, we can feel like things are a little bit stale and that this is not the time for things to be stale, that we want it to be exciting. That is an experience I'm relating to a lot at the moment. You know, despite all the beautiful things, I've been staying in Bondi quite a bit. I've been working really hard on some new projects. Sometimes it just feels like I'm a little bit restless and I'm ready for a new adventure and I've been kind of tossing up two big things.
几个原因。第一，我觉得我最近有点缺乏灵感，思维也有点单薄。其实，我这周晚些时候要录制的一期节目就是关于为什么生活会感觉无聊，因为我认为有时候在我们二十多岁的时候，我们会觉得事情有点停滞不前，而现在可不是停滞不线的时候，我们希望生活充满刺激。这确实是我目前深有同感的一种体验。你知道，尽管有那么多美好的事物，我还是在邦迪呆了挺长时间的。我一直在为一些新项目努力工作。有时我只是觉得有些坐立不安，渴望一次新的冒险，我一直在纠结两件大事。
Number one is moving to a new city either in Australia, although I've kind of exhausted my options considering I have lived in most places on the East Coast and I'm sorry to my Australian listeners, I do not want to move to Perth, but also moving overseas. And I know that is a fantasy that we all kind of have, like, specifically the like New York, L.A., Paris, London kind of vibe. And it is one that I'm very willingly buying into. The second big thing that I've really been considering is going back to school for something like unrelated to psychology.
第一件是搬到一个新城市，要么在澳大利亚，尽管考虑到澳洲东海岸大部分地方我都住过了，我的选择有点枯竭了，而且对我的澳洲听众说声抱歉，我真的不想搬去珀斯；要么就是搬到海外去。我知道这是我们都会有的某种幻想，特别是那种纽约、洛杉矶、巴黎、伦敦式的氛围。而且我也非常乐意去买账。我真正考虑的第二件大事是重返校园，去学一些和心理学无关的东西。
I think something scary about working in like podcasting or even like the entertainment space. even in like social media, although I don't know, I don't think my main job is social media, but, you know, still in that space where it's like your ability to support yourself and kind of your worth is almost tied to the amount of attention people are willing to give you. And so when people get bored of you, when like your content is no longer like trendy or like captivating their attention, you are kind of out of a job, right? And I think that that is a fear that a lot of people have in the space. like, I'm only able to do this as long as people are willing to listen.
我觉得在播客或者娱乐领域工作，甚至在社交媒体领域工作，有一个可怕的地方——虽然我不知道，我也不认为我的主要工作是社交媒体，但你知道，在那个领域里，你养活自己的能力和你的价值几乎与人们愿意给予你的关注度挂钩。所以，当人们对你感到厌倦，当你的内容不再时髦或无法吸引他们的注意力时，你基本上就失业了，对吧？我想这也是这个领域里很多人都有的一种恐惧。就像，只要别人还愿意听，我才能做这件事。
And yeah, we have so many new listeners. It's like the most amazing, beautiful blessing. But I do have a lot of that fear around the future. I am someone who catastrophizes and has a lot of anxiety, which really, I think, manifests in overthinking and a lot of, like, trying to control the future. And one way that I've been contemplating, like, kind of how to protect myself from not having a job, I guess, or protect myself from
是的，我们有这么多的新听众。这就像是最惊人、最美丽的祝福。但我对未来确实有很多这种恐惧。我是一个会把事情灾难化并有很大焦虑的人，这实际上我认为表现为过度思考以及很多试图控制未来的想法。我一直在考虑的一种方法是，如何保护自己不失业，或者保护自己免受
what if I do fail, like, what if I don't want to do this anymore, is to kind of get some future study plans in the works and kind of think about, like, the direction that I could not only take this show, but I could also take my life that maybe expands beyond psychology and also our 20s, like a question I get all the time is like, what are you going to do when you turn 30? And you know what? I have no freaking clue. I have no clue. Like, the life expectancy of this maybe only has like another six years. I'm hoping that it lasts longer, but it is like something that I do really question a lot. So thinking about either going back to school for something unrelated and also moving, you know, and if I were to move, I, like, because I'm going to New York and
万一我失败了怎么办，万一我不想再做这个了怎么办，那就是把一些未来的学习计划提上日程，并开始思考我不仅能把这个节目带向何方，还能把我的生活带向何方，这些方向可能超越心理学，也超越我们的二十多岁。比如我经常被问到的一个问题是：你三十岁的时候打算做什么？你知道吗？我特么一点头绪也没有。我真的毫无头绪。这个节目的生命力可能也就只有大约六年了。我希望它能持续更久，但这确实是我经常认真思考的问题。所以我在考虑要么回学校学点不相关的专业，还要搬家，你知道的，如果我要搬家的话，因为我
LA in the summer for a month and a half. So if you are there, please reach out. I need to know the things to do. I need to know the sites. I don't know. just want to go to like the Empire State Building and I don't know time square so if you've got some hidden hideouts please let me know also would be cute to do a meetup if people are interested in that but I'm going to New York and L.A. this summer and then also to Tokyo not to like think about moving there but just to actually explore and for leisure time and part of that though is this like I think testing the waters around like is this a place that I could live is this a place that I could live is this a place where I could actually see myself building community?
要在夏天去纽约和洛杉矶呆一个半月。所以如果你也在那里，请联系我。我需要知道有哪些好玩的，我需要知道有哪些景点。我不知道，我只是想去帝国大厦和时代广场看看，如果你有什么秘密基地，请告诉我。如果大家有兴趣的话，能去面基一下也很可爱。但我今年夏天要去纽约和洛杉矶，然后还要去东京，倒不是为了考虑搬到那里去，而纯粹是为了探索和享受闲暇时光。不过，其中一部分原因也是在试水，比如：这是个我可以居住的地方吗？这是个我可以生活的地方吗？这是一个我能真正看到自己建立社群的地方吗？
And that is like the biggest factor for me when I consider or like weigh up the pros and cons of moving to a new city or moving to a new country. Like could I find my place here? Could this be my home? And the things that I think about are obviously being away from family and friends. Also I've got a boyfriend now to consider who I would preferably like to stay with and kind of gauging what our plans are together whilst also not rushing things. also things like, would this city have good infrastructure for the job that I do? Would it have good public transport? You know, I think L.A. is out there. But also, like, just good community and, like, nice outdoor spaces. So it is something that I really want to do within, I would say, like,
这对我来说是考虑或权衡搬到一个新城市或新国家的利弊时最大的因素。比如我能在这里找到我的归属吗？这里能成为我的家吗？我所考虑的事情显然包括远离家人和朋友。另外我现在还有一个男朋友需要考虑，我更希望我们能在一起，并评估我们未来的计划，同时也不要操之过急。还有一些事情，比如这个城市对我的工作有好的基础设施吗？它有好的公共交通吗？你知道，我觉得洛杉矶就算了。但还有，就是要有好的社群和漂亮的户外空间。所以这确实是我非常想在
the next year or two, even if it's just for, like, three or six months doing, like, a radio fellowship or something like that. If anyone from This American Life is listening, please give me a job. It would be my dream. Just going to put it out there. manifested into the universe, but it is like really been something on my mind. Like where where to next? It's the restless fate syndrome, right? Like, why is my life not exciting enough right now? What do I need to do to change that? As someone who is also, I think, very solutions focused. This like feels like a big, a big change that is necessary and that would also, I think, kind of fix a lot of my problems. And I posted a TikTok like this about this, like,
未来一两年内做的事情，哪怕只是花三六个月做一个电台奖学金项目之类的事。如果有任何《美国生活》（This American Life）的人在听，请给我一份工作。这将是我的梦想。我只是把它说出来。让它在宇宙中显化，但这确实是一直在我脑海里的事情。比如，接下来去哪里？这就是躁动命运综合症，对吧？比如，为什么我现在的的生活还不够刺激？我需要做些什么来改变这一点？作为一个我认为也非常注重解决方案的人。这感觉像是一个重大改变，是必要的，而且我认为这也将解决我的很多问题。我发了一条关于这个的TikTok，像这样
recently and this like person commented being like it's not going to change your problems like running away from your problems is never the solution and I was like yeah you're probably right but then also I think my problems would look a lot better eating one dollar pizza in New York or having an apparel in Italy and also the problems that I'm like quote unquote running away from is not really a problem it's just boredom it's just like a lack of excitement and maybe a lack of novelty that I'm feeling uncomfortable with. So that has also been on my mind. If you are having similar thoughts about this, can you please reach out? Because I know that I cannot be the only one. We need like a support group or something like that. A support group for people in their 20s or even
最近，然后有个人评论说：这不会改变你的问题，逃避问题永远不是解决办法。我当时就想：是的，你说得可能对。但同时我也觉得，如果在纽约吃着一美元的比萨，或者在意大利喝着Aperol酒，我的问题看起来会好很多。而且我所谓的“逃避”并不是真正的问题，只是无聊，只是缺乏刺激，也许是对这种缺乏新鲜感感到不舒服。所以这也是我一直在考虑的事情。如果你也有类似的想法，能联系我吗？因为我知道我绝不是唯一的一个。我们需要一个互助会或类似的东西。为那些二十多岁甚至
their 30s or beyond who are constantly restless and constantly looking for like new adventure. And if you are someone who has managed to like make that part of your lifestyle, how did you do it? because I need to do a series on this if I ever decide to make that decision. I feel like the idea is one thing, the execution is another. So let's kind of, let's gather all our thoughts and collective knowledge here. Some other exciting things. Okay, so I'm going to announce this here for the people who have listened this far, but if you have been watching closely, there is a book in the works.
三十岁及以上、不断焦躁不安、不断寻找新冒险的人建立的互助会。如果你是那种设法将这一点融入生活方式的人，你是怎么做到的？因为如果我决定做出那个决定，我需要做一个关于这个的系列节目。我觉得想法是一回事，执行又是另一回事。所以让我们在这里收集我们所有的想法和集体智慧吧。还有其他一些令人兴奋的事情。好吧，我要在这里向听到这里的听众宣布这个消息，但如果你一直在密切关注，一本新书正在筹备中。
and it has been an experience moving from audio to kind of written work. And a little known fact is that a lot of my podcasts are actually scripted just because of the level of evidence base and kind of some of the studies that we saw. So I want to make sure that they're accurate and that the definitions and the ideas that I'm giving are coming from a place of like factual evidence-based knowledge. but now that's been a lot more of what I've been doing is writing heaps and looking for a publisher and trying to get it out into people's hands. And the anxiety around whether people will buy it is also very pressing because I think any time you take a risk and try and do something new, the first kind of response or fear response is always like, and what if I fail?
从音频转向文字工作真是一次独特的体验。一个鲜为人知的事实是，我的许多播客其实都是写了剧本的，这主要是基于证据的水平以及我们看到的一些研究。所以我希望确保它们的准确性，并且我给出的定义和观点都来自于基于事实的证据支持的知识。但现在我做得更多的是写大量的文章，寻找出版商，并试图把它送到人们手中。对于人们是否会买账的焦虑也是非常紧迫的，因为我认为任何时候当你冒险尝试新事物时，第一种反应或恐惧反应总是：万一我失败了怎么办？
So that has been keeping me up at night. But I also just, it's like one of my lifelong goals is to write a book. And even if it's just my mom and my grandma buying it and like my friends, I think I would still be happy with that. I would still be happy just to own a copy and be proud of what I've written. And hopefully if a stranger picks it up one day in like a secondhand bookshop for them to be like, I wonder who this is and come back and find these podcasts when I'm like 80 years old. So that's really like what's been on my mind, guest episode. as well. Gosh, if you guys have any suggestions, I really, really picky. Like, I really want to have
所以这让我彻夜难眠。但我也只是觉得，写一本书是我一生的目标之一。哪怕只有我妈妈、我奶奶和我的朋友们买，我觉得我也会很满足。我依然会很高兴能拥有自己的一份复本，并为自己写的东西感到骄傲。希望如果有一天某个陌生人在二手书店里随手翻到它，会想“这人是谁呀”，然后在我八十岁的时候来找这些播客听。所以这真的是我一直在想的事情，还有嘉宾客串。天哪，如果你有什么建议的话，我真的很挑剔。因为我真的很想邀请
people on who I share a philosophy with, the one that I deeply believe in. And I think I'm getting so many more opportunities to explore that, but I do have, like, some dream guests on the agenda. Someone like Courtney Dolewater, if you don't know who that is, you should really look her up. I've been obsessed with her, like, running career. She is, like, the best ultra-marathoner in the world. male or female. This is like such a weird fact that has nothing to do with psychology or the 20s or even me. But did you know that like ultra running is one of the only sports in which women like consistently beat men? Because it is such a mental game. And they like have all these theories that like
那些与我有着相同哲学理念、我深信不疑的人来做节目。我觉得我有很多探索这方面的机会，但我的日程表上确实有一些梦想嘉宾。比如像科特妮·多尔沃特（Courtney Dauwalter），如果你不知道她是谁，你真的应该去查查她。我一直对她的跑步生涯着迷。她是世界上最棒的超级马拉松运动员，无论男女。这是一个非常奇怪的事实，它与心理学、二十岁的人生甚至我都没有任何关系。但你知道超级长跑是唯一一项女性能 consistently（持续地）击败男性的运动吗？因为这是一场极度考验心理的比赛。他们有各种各样的理论认为
women have better psychological toughness or psychological strength. So they're able to win. But I would love to have her on the show or one of the Matildas like if you're an Aussie, you will know the absolute pandemonium that was caused after the World Cup and like seeing women's sport being appreciated and followed and given funding and support by everyone was just like incredible and I want to be able to really explore like maybe even the athletes mentality or like a winner's mentality how to cope with failure not just for those of us who are athletes you know I am not an athlete so the majority of us who are not professional athletes but just like how we can bring that like philosophy and some of that sports psychology into our lives.
女性具有更好的心理韧性或心理实力。所以她们能够获胜。但我很乐意邀请她来节目，或者像Matildas（澳大利亚女足国家队）的成员——如果你是个澳洲人，你就会知道世界杯之后引起的绝对轰动，看到女子运动受到赞赏、关注，并得到所有人的资金和支持，简直是太不可思议了。我想真正探讨一下运动员的心态或赢家的心态，如何应对失败，不仅针对我们这些运动员（你知道，我不是运动员），而是针对我们这些绝大多数不是职业运动员的人，我们如何将这种哲学和一些运动心理学应用到我们的生活中。
So those have been some of the big things. But what I do want to talk about after this short break is also where I'm at just in terms of my move to Sydney. I moved to Sydney like around a year and a half ago. I want to give an update on that. And then I'm going to do like a rapid fire Q&A of some of the questions you guys sent in. So stay tuned for that after this short break. 2%. That is the number of people.
所以这些都是一些大事。但在短暂的休息之后，我真正想谈的是我目前搬到悉尼的近况。我大约一年半前搬到了悉尼。我想对此做一个更新。然后我将对你们发过来的一些问题进行一次快问快答。所以请在短暂的休息后继续收听。2%。这就是那个比例——
who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress.
在有自动扶梯可用时，依然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter），在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析精神韧性、健身以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立复原力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等展开对话，打破主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的认为种子油本质上会引起炎症。我们弄错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题都是压力造成的。
Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess. with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And rule two, never mess with her friends either. We always say that trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield, and in this new season of the girlfriends, oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care. So they take matters into their own.
经历一些艰难困苦，你最终会成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的自己。收听《2%》。这就是T-W-O-Percent，在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方。任何男人都应该遵守两条黄金法则。法则一，千万别惹乡村女孩。你在玩愚蠢的游戏，就会得到愚蠢的下场。法则二，也千万别惹她的朋友。我们总是说，相信你的闺蜜。我是安娜·辛菲尔德（Anna Sinfield），在新一季的《女友们》（The Girlfriends）中，“天哪，这是同一个人。”一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会过。我感觉像被卡车撞了一样。我想，这怎么会发生在我身上？警察似乎并不在乎。所以她们决定自己动手。
hands. I said, oh, hell no. I vowed. I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Al. Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s.
我心想，哦，见鬼，绝不。我发誓。我要成为他的最后一个目标。他会得到应有的下场。收听《女友们》。相信我，宝贝。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方。还记得黛安娜·罗斯（Diana Ross）在VMA颁奖典礼上拍了两下莉儿·金（Lil' Kim）的胸部吗？或者当坎耶（Kanye）说乔治·布什（George Bush）不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟莉儿·金到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《回顾过去》（Look Back at It）播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·J（Sam J.）。我是Al，亚历克斯·英格利士（Alex English）。每集节目中，我们都会挑选一个事件，剖析事情的经过，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。包括最近一期与马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）的访谈，大谈80年代的可卡因。
To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack, so I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now, so. Thank you finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah.
需要说明的是，84年对我很重要，不仅仅是因为可卡因。我愿意在任何一天聊可卡因，只是让你们知道而已。我的意思是，马克，这已经是我们第二期讨论可卡因了，所以我开始看出一条贯穿始终的主线了。我们现在还要讨论艾滋病，所以。谢谢你把话说完。我认为没有哪一年对黑人来说比这更重要了。真的吗？是的。
For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking. Trip Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing
对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。收听《回顾过去》，在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方。欢迎来到我的新播客《硬核学习》（Learn the Hard Way），我是你的主持人，也是你最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯（Kear Games）。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我将把我在心理健康领域十多年的经验以及与众多不可思议的嘉宾的对话带给大家。我说的是。特里普·方丹（Trip Fontaine）、瑞安·克拉克（Ryan Clark）。有时，当我们追求某样东西时，我们太专注于追逐，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了它，
and we're still chasing it and we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth, or are you a good person because you're afraid?
却依然在盲目追逐，不知道什么时候才算足够。因为人们总是盯着记分牌看。生活变成了关于输赢的较量。史蒂夫·伯恩斯（Steve Burns）、达斯汀·罗斯（Dustin Ross），因为你觉得作为一个在世的好人很重要，还是你只是因为害怕才做一个好人？
Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, is we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. Okay, so something else that people ask me about regularly is how my move to Sydney has been going.
因为兄弟，这是两种不同的动机。绝对的。这也是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你能真正地做一个好人。和我基尔·盖恩斯一起，在我的新播客《硬核学习》中，就疗愈、成长、父爱、压力和目标展开真实的对话。打开你免费的iHeartRadio应用程序。搜索《硬核学习》，现在就收听。好的，那么人们经常问我的另一件事是，我搬到悉尼的生活过得怎么样。
So I went to Canberra for uni. and then you know what's ironic is that I'm talking about moving to a new city realizing that I had that exact same feeling like almost two years ago and I did it and now like I'm in that new place feeling like the need to move to another new place but I moved to Sydney like a year and half ago and I talked about on the podcast a lot like back at the start of my last life update how difficult it was and if you are someone who was far away from your community or your home or your hometown, you will really, I think, understand that there is like a six month period when you first move somewhere new where it kind
我在堪培拉上的大学。然后，你知道具有讽刺意味的是什么吗？当我谈到要搬到一个新城市时，我意识到自己大约两年前也有过那种一模一样的感觉，而我也确实付诸行动了。现在我又在那个新地方感到了需要搬到另一个新地方的冲动。但我大约在一年前半前搬到了悉尼，我在播客里经常谈到这一点——回到我上一个生活更新的初期，那段日子有多么艰难。如果你是一个远离你的社群、你的家或你的家乡的人，我想你真的会明白，当你初到一个新地方时，大概会有六个月的时期，
just really sucks. And you don't really have many friends yet. You don't really have community yet, literally like the basic needs for like human fulfillment. And you're kind of just like grasping its straws for bringing like meaning into your life or even entertainment. And And the last time I spoke about this, I was kind of stuck, I think, in a place of feeling like I'd made the wrong decision. And then I needed to move back to where I was previously living. But I'm happy to report that since then, yes, it has been a while, but things have just, like, changed so much. And I want to come and come on here and just really say, like, that six-month theory of, like, you need six months to adjust to a new place is absolutely correct. because I've now found that, like, I am feeling so at place.
那段日子真的是糟透了。你还没有什么朋友。你还没有建立社群，而这些简直是人类满足感的基本需求。你只是在苦苦寻找能给生活带来意义甚至娱乐的东西。上次我谈到这件事时，我好像陷入了一种困境，觉得自己做出了错误的决定。然后我需要搬回我之前住的地方。但我很高兴地向大家汇报，自那以后——是的，确实过去了一段时间——情况已经发生了太大的变化。我想来到这里并真诚地说，那种“你需要六个月的时间来适应一个新地方”的六个月理论绝对是正确的。因为我发现，现在我真的感觉非常适应。
I have the most incredible friendship group. I have met the most incredible people. I understand my neighborhood now. I'm even friends with my neighbors. Stu and Andy, if you guys are listening, you guys are freaking legends. They literally let me, they're, like, screwdrivers the other day, all of them, because I was, like, building a new bed frame. And it's just, like, I feel like I'm kind of living, like, the dream a little bit,
我拥有了最棒的朋友圈。我遇到了最不可思议的人。我现在了解我的街区了。我甚至和邻居成了朋友。斯图（Stu）和安迪（Andy），如果你们在听的话，你们简直是传奇。前几天我组装新床架的时候，他们甚至把螺丝刀借给了我。我觉得自己现在有点像在过着梦想中的生活，
despite what I was saying about my restless fever, like, I do truly feel like I've kind of come into my own in this new city. And I'm really in, like, what I would say is my hosting error. One of the things that I love doing so much as, and I really, like, have to thank my mother for this, thank you, mom, is, like, hosting people at my house. And when I first moved to Sydney, I did not have the opportunity to do that because I didn't have any friends. I knew, like, four people, five people, and they are not always available on the same night. So like a dinner party with two people is kind of, is a little bit sad. Like, you know, the wine can be flowing and it's still, it's not the thing that I was envisioning, but something I've been doing so much
尽管我刚才一直在抱怨我的躁动狂热，但我真的觉得在这个新城市里我找到了真正的自我。我真的进入了我所说的“做东时代”。我很喜欢做的一件事——我真的得感谢我妈妈，谢谢你，妈妈——就是在家里招待别人。当我刚搬到悉尼时，我没有机会这样做，因为我没有朋友。我只认识四五个人，而且他们不可能总是在同一个晚上都有空。所以只有两个人的晚宴未免有点凄凉。你知道的，虽然酒可以一直倒，但这依然不是我所设想的场景。但最近我经常做的一件事是举办小型烧烤晚会或小晚宴，一起玩桌游。我真的进入了我的“轻松做东时代”。我在几周前的“如何充分利用二十多岁”那期节目里谈过这个，你真的需要成为那个为他人创造能带来感激之情的社群的人。如果你想要那个朋友圈，如果你想要那些人脉，你就必须走出去争取。你必须成为那个为他人创造这些记忆并带来某种灵感的人。所以这是我最近一直在优先处理的事情，同时还有我所有的全新工作事务。我们有了一个工作室空间。如果你看过Instagram上的视频内容，
recently is like hosting little barbecues or little dinner parties, playing board games. I've really entered like my soft hosting era where I spoke about this on the making the most out of my 20s which was like a couple weeks back, you really need to be the one who makes the community that other people are going to be grateful for. You, if you want that friendship group, if you want those connections, you have to go out and get them. You have to be the one who creates those memories for other people and kind of set a bit of an inspiration. And so that's been something I've been really prioritizing as of late alongside all of my new work things as well. We have a studio space. If you've seen the video content on Instagram. You will know it is stunning. It is beautiful. And also,
你就会知道它非常惊艳。它太漂亮了。而且，
I just recently decided with the, with like a bunch of other creators, um, these two girls who run two broke chicks, they were on for an episode. We've been friends for some time and a bunch of other creators that we were going to rent like a little office space. Because something about freelancing and working from home is that it is exhausting and incredibly lonely to have no one to talk to throughout the day until all your nine to five friends get off work. And so we rented this like adorable studio space. We go in two times a week and that is like the perfect amount to still feel connected to like a larger community of people doing the same things as you. And then also have that like flexibility and time to do the things that you need to do outside of like the workplace.
我最近和一群其他的创作者——运营《两个破妞》（Two Broke Chicks）的那两个女孩，她们曾作为嘉宾上过节目，我们已经做了一段时间的朋友，还有其他一些创作者——决定一起租一个小办公室。因为自由职业和在家工作的一点是，一整天都没有人说话，直到你所有朝九晚五的朋友下班为止，这种状态既让人筋疲力尽又无比孤独。所以我们租了这个超级可爱的工作室空间。我们一周去两次，这简直是完美的频率，既能让你感觉与做着同样事情的更大社群保持着联系，又能拥有灵活性和时间去处理工作场所以外你需要做的事情。
It has really honestly changed like changed my life at the moment. It's been such a contributing factor to, I would say, my enjoyment and my happiness in this period of my life, obviously other things as well, but having like a space to go and like having people to chat to one of the biggest parts about my transition from full-time work was losing out on some of those like very convenient friendships. And I feel like that has kind of restored things for me. So all in all, I feel like I'm doing super well and just in like a really happy space, a productive space. a lovely, loved space. I want to do like a quick rapid fire Q&A. I asked if you guys had any questions and I was kind of debating whether to like include this, but I feel like the questions
老实说，它真的改变了我的生活。它成为了我现阶段生活乐趣和幸福感的重要推动力，当然还有其他一些事情，但拥有一个可以去的地方和可以聊天的人真的很重要。我从全职工作过渡到自由职业时，最大的部分之一就是失去了那些非常便利的友情。我觉得这在某种程度上为我恢复了这些。所以总的来说，我觉得我过得超级好，处于一个非常快乐、富有成效、充满爱意的空间里。我想做一个快速的快问快答。我问过你们是否有任何问题，我一度在纠结是否要把这个包含进来，但我觉得这些问题
are really good and maybe informative if you're feeling the same way. All righty. So question time, here we go. The first one is, how am I? I feel like I've answered that. I am feeling very happy, very content, very safe, but then also a little bit uninspired at the moment looking for like some challenges. All in a day's work, I think you can go on this bit of emotional roller coaster where like one time, at some time you're feeling amazing and then you're feeling a little bit crappy and you're feeling a little bit down. So just kind of rolling with the punches at the moment. Okay, this next question was really cute. What has been your favorite memory from the past few months? So because I am a massive, I think kind of silent fan of women's sport, I have to include this here.
真的很好，如果你也有同感的话，或许会有所启发。好了，那么提问时间，我们开始吧。第一个问题是，我最近怎么样？我觉得我已经回答过了。我感到非常快乐、非常满足、非常安全，但同时最近也觉得有点缺乏灵感，正在寻找一些挑战。我觉得这就是工作的一部分，你会经历这种情绪过山车，有时你在某个时刻感觉棒极了，然后又觉得有点糟糕，有点沮丧。所以目前就是兵来将挡，水来土掩。好吧，接下来的这个问题非常可爱。这几个月来你最喜欢的记忆是什么？因为我是女子运动的超级、我认为可以说是默默的粉丝，所以我必须把这个包含在这里。
I went to the Matilda's semi-final. For those of you who have been following along with the FIFA World Cup, it is finished now. Spain did win, rest in peace, the Matildas, the Australian team. But I went to that game and it was insane. It was like the most attended female sporting game in Australian history. It was, and everyone was like an Aussie fan. It was so infectious, so contagious. Then we lost.
我去了Matildas（澳大利亚女足）的半决赛。对于那些一直关注国际足联女足世界杯的人来说，它现在已经结束了。西班牙赢了，愿澳大利亚女足安息吧。但我去看了那场比赛，简直太疯狂了。那是澳大利亚历史上上座率最高的女子体育比赛。而且每个人都是澳洲球迷。那种氛围太有感染力了。然后我们输了。
oops but and I got stuck on the train on the way home but you know what all and all it was a really beautiful memory I also went to garrangong recently which is like a tiny country town in Australia like on the New South Wales coast would totally recommend it like summer is coming in Australia you guys
哎呀，不过在回家的路上我还被困在了火车上，但你知道吗，总的来说，这是一段非常美好的回忆。我最近还去了格兰贡（Gerringong），那是澳大利亚的一个小乡村城镇，位于新南威尔士州海岸，强烈推荐。澳大利亚的夏天就要来了，你们
you like US European like North I don't know North American girlies have had your summertime it's our time now it's time for an Australian in summer, the best kind of summer, and I can, like, really feel it coming in. So having those, like, small choice moments where I've been enjoying the outdoors and enjoying the beach have been beautiful. Okay, the next question. Biggest life lesson from this year. I, oh, my goodness, I need
这些美国、欧洲、北美的小姐姐们已经过完你们的夏天了，现在轮到我们了，是时候迎来澳洲的夏天了，这可是最棒的夏天，我真的能感觉到它正在走来。所以能拥有那些享受户外、享受海滩的美好精选时刻，真的很棒。好的，下一个问题。今年最大的生活教训。我，天哪，我需要
to think about that. I would say I have two here, and they kind of relate, but the first one is to say yes to everything. So much about my life has changed this year because I've been willing to put myself out of my comfort zone even when sometimes it doesn't work out but the majority of times I think that some force has rewarded me for my courage so saying yes to everything and my second lesson is that you cannot try and plan too much for the future and you cannot kind of plan the most beautiful things that life has in store for you and I think that relates to why you should say yes more because it really opens you up to those experiences and you know like a big thing we've spoken about is my new relationship. Obviously that was a surprise that came from me
想一想。我想我这里有两个，它们有点关联，但第一个是对所有事情说“好”。我今年的生活发生了很多变化，因为我愿意让自己走出舒适区，即使有时结果并不尽如人意，但在大多数情况下，我觉得某种力量为我的勇气给予了回报。所以对所有事情都说“好”。我的第二个教训是，你无法为未来做太多规划，你也无法规划生活为你准备的最美好的事物。我认为这与你为什么应该多说“好”有关，因为它确实让你向这些体验敞开了心扉。你知道，我们一直在谈论的一个大事就是我的新恋情。显然那是一个惊喜，来自于我
saying yes. And there was so many like invisible, there was such an invisible string that's been like tied between meeting this person and then also all these things in my past. But I really do think that that's a part of my new philosophy. And also, you know, we're more than halfway through the year. I hope it's one that I carry through into 2024. Okay, next question. What is my attachment style and how have I become more secure? So really relates to the first half, I think that sometimes we get confused with attachment style by thinking that it's like something that we can decide
说了“好”。而且有那么多看不见的线，把遇到这个人以及我过去的种种经历紧紧地联系在了一起。但我真的认为这是我的新哲学的一部分。而且你知道，今年已经过了一半多了。我希望我能把这一点带入2024年。好的，下一个问题。我的依恋风格是什么，以及我是如何变得更有安全感的？这确实与前半部分有关，我认为有时我们对依恋风格感到困惑，以为它是我们可以决定的，
and thinking that it's something that is very, I don't know, like negligible and movable or flexible. I would say that I've always been a securely attached person given my understanding that attachment style really does come from like parental influences and my parents were, an amazing, are an amazing set of people who have really guided me to find good love. But then also there is the acknowledgement that events in our early teens and also in our early adulthood, certain relationships, certain betrayals, certain instances of abandonment can really shape us
并且认为它是一个非常、我不知道，可以忽略、可以移动或灵活的东西。我想说，鉴于我理解依恋风格确实来自于父母的影响，而我的父母是一对非常了不起的人，他们真正引导我找到了好的爱情，所以我一直是一个安全型依恋的人。但同时，我们也承认，我们青春期早期以及成年初期发生的事件、某些关系、某些背叛、某些被抛弃的实例，确实可以把我们塑造
into becoming people who are perhaps more anxiously attached. So I would say that the past two years have been one that has been defined by a lot of anxiously attached. symptoms or signs. When this, the second part of this question is like, how do you become more secure? And I think I can speak to that more and it's around, I would say, making deliberate decisions around who gets to love you in the sense that if you want to cure your, or cure, if you want to heal your anxious or ambivalent or dismissive attachment style, I think that is hard to do. without having practice and without having people challenge you. So sometimes when we are anxiously attached or people who become anxiously attached,
成可能更偏向焦虑型依恋的人。所以我想说，过去这两年，我身上有很多焦虑型依恋的症状或表现。这道问题的第二部分是：你如何变得更有安全感？我想我可以对此说更多，这大约围绕着，我会说，在谁能来爱你的问题上做出深思熟虑的决定——意思就是，如果你想治愈你的——或者说治愈，如果你想治愈你的焦虑型、矛盾型或回避型依恋风格，我认为如果没有经历过实践，没有经历过有人对你发起挑战，这是很难做到的。所以有时当我们是焦虑型依恋时，或者变得焦虑型依恋的人，
that can lead, or even someone who's avoided, that can lead to a lot of anxiety and sometimes a lot of avoidance or emotional insecurity around entering into new relationships. If you find someone who is going to meet you in the middle and who you can tell will really attempt to understand you and understand where perhaps some of these responses or triggers or reactions are coming from. I do truly believe that it's one of the most healing things we can experience when it comes to our attachment style. But also it comes, it also, you know, requires action and agency from you as well. You really need to kind of at times over-communicate your needs and you need to ask for reassurance when you are in a situation that may be challenging
这可能会导致，或者甚至是回避型的人，这会导致很多焦虑，有时在进入新关系时还会导致很多回避或情感上的不安全感。如果你找到了一个愿意在中间与你相遇、并且你能看出他真的会试图去理解你以及理解这些反应、触发点或应激反应可能从何而来的人。我真的相信，这是我们在依恋风格方面能经历的最具疗愈的事情之一。但这同时也需要你自己的行动和主观能动性。你确实需要在某些时候过度表达你的需求，在处于可能对你具有挑战性的情况时，你需要寻求安抚，并要有勇气去展现脆弱。因为我认为如果你和对的人在一起，并且向他们表达了你为什么会有某种感受、为什么会有某种行为，如果他们是一个好人，如果他们注定出现在你的生命中，他们就会理解并给予回应。这就是我对此的建议。我是否会收到批评？我是如何应对这些批评的？是的，百分之百会。其实一直都会。哦，也不是一直都会。有时候。其实，如果你去看看我在中国的评价——这太随机了，但有那么一个人一直在用负面评价刷屏播客，因为他们出于某种原因无法收听某些节目。
for you and have the courage to be vulnerable because I think that if you are with the right person and you communicate to them, perhaps why you're feeling a certain way, why you're behaving a certain way, if they're a good person, if they're meant to be in your life, they will understand and reciprocate that back. So there is my advice on that. Do I receive criticisms and how do I deal with these? Yes, 100%. All the time, actually. Oh, not all the time. Sometimes. Actually, If you look at my like reviews in China, this is so random, but there's like this one person who has been like spamming the podcast with negative reviews because they for some reason cannot listen to certain episodes.
我觉得这纯粹是他们自己的问题。我第一次看到的时候心想：天哪，他们恨死我了。我怎么能为他们解决这个问题呢？我甚至试图去联系他们。然后我想：Gemma，你不可能为了让某个人更喜欢你而去控制中国的互联网访问权限。所以我想这大概回答了“我是如何回应或处理这些问题的”。你知道，我觉得人们总是喜欢对各种事情发表意见。
And I think it's just like a them problem. And when I first saw that, I was like, oh my God, they hate me. How do I fix this for them? I like tried to get in contact with them. And then I was like, Gemma, you cannot control internet access in China just to make someone like you more. So I think that that kind of answers, how do I respond or deal with these? You know, I think sometimes people are always, people always like to have opinions about things.
这是身为人类美好的一部分。我注意到并意识到，有些人在这方面并不总是那么友善。他们总能从任何事情中挑出他们不喜欢的地方。但我认为这归结于认识到这来自于他们自身的 insecurity（不安全感），或者是因为他们有着根深蒂固的观点，而这两点你都无法改变。所以，只要你身边有那些你信任其观点的人，并且你知道如果你的话说过头了或者你的某些做法可能不够标准，他们会直言不讳，这就足够重要了。并且要意识到一切都是暂时的，比如，我收到过一些相当刻薄的信息，让我难过了几天。但如果你现在问我那是什么内容，我可能已经记不清了。
That's a beautiful part about being human. I've noticed and realized that some people are not always nice about that. They will find things that they don't like about anything. But I think it comes to like recognizing that that comes from a place of insecurity from them or because of a deep opinion, neither of which you can change. So as long as you have people around you whose opinions you do trust and who you know will say if perhaps you've said the wrong thing or if something you've done is maybe not up to scratch, that is really important. And just realizing everything's temporary, like, I've gotten some pretty mean messages that have, like, hurt me for a few days. And then if you ask me what they were now, I probably couldn't tell you.
所以这一切都会过去的。这只是这个领域的一部分。好了，最后一个问题，因为这期节目已经比我预期的要长得多了。现在大约30分钟了。所以这个问题非常美好。我想在这里结束。你是否处于自我成长的某个阶段，能够100%地爱自己？当我读到这个问题时，我其实愣了一下，因为我最初的回答是：是的。就像，是的，当然。但随后我真的思考了一下，我认为我们永远不可能达到100%爱自己的阶段，也许这有点
So it all comes to pass. It's just part of the territory. All right. last question because this episode has gone on for way longer than I wanted it to. It's like 30 minutes now. So this one was a really beautiful one. And I want to finish here. Are you at a point in your growth where you 100% love yourself? When I read this question, it actually made me do a double take because I, my initial answer was like, yes. Like yes, of course. And then I really thought about it and I think that we can never be at a point where we are 100% love ourselves and maybe that's a
具争议性，但我认为重要的是永远有你在努力争取的方向，而且你总能更爱自己一点。所以，如果问我是不是处于一个比以往任何时候都更爱自己的阶段？答案是肯定的。关于这一点，我真的想说两点，因为我曾和我男友谈过我十几岁晚期、二十岁初期的样子，我们一起翻看照片和我和一些最好朋友的旧短信。我的生活当时简直操蛋的混乱。真的太混乱了。总是有些这样那样的抓马在发生，或者有什么不对劲的地方，或者有些问题。我意识到，我真的达到了某种平静的境界，我绝对回不去
little bit controversial but I think that it's important to always have things that you're working towards and you can always love yourself more. So I think in terms of am I at a point where I've loved myself more than I ever have before? The answer to that is yes. I've really come to two things I want to say about this because I was talking to my boyfriend about it around what I was like during my late teens, early 20s, and we were looking back through, like, photos and all text messages I had with some of my best friends. And my life was so fucking chaotic. Like, it was so chaotic. There was always some kind of drama going on or something that was wrong or some problem. And I realized that, like, I've really achieved a level of peace and I could never go back
那个极度狂热的时期了。所以我想说，这大大促进了我对自己的爱。此外，我最近一直在进行这种激进的自我同情之旅。如果你是常客，你就会知道这个术语的来历。但 是的，我真的一直在经历这段旅程，去接受那些我无法改变的事情，无论如何都去爱那个不完美的自己。所以我喜欢这个问题。我认为这是我们都应该问自己的一个问题：我们是否达到了100%爱自己的阶段？我们还能更爱自己吗？我想我对这两个问题的回答是“否”和“是”。我绝对认为我可以更爱自己。也许我永远不会达到100%，但说实话，我现在过得挺好的。所以非常感谢你们的所有问题。谢谢你们一直听到这里，
to that really frenzied time. So I would say that has greatly contributed to myself, love. Also, I've just been really on this radical self-compassion journey. If you were a frequent listener, you will know where that term comes from. But yeah, I've really been on this journey around accepting the things I cannot change and loving myself for them anyways. So I like this question. I think it's one that we should all ask ourselves. Are we at a point where we 100% love ourselves? And could we love ourselves more? And I think I, the answer to both of those is no and yes. I definitely think I could love myself more. Maybe I'll never be at 100%, but I'll be honest, I'm doing pretty well right now. So I appreciate all of your questions. I appreciate that if you've
回到那段狂热的时期。所以我可以说这极大地促进了我的自爱。此外，我也一直在进行这种激进的自我同情之旅。如果你是常客，你就会知道这个术语的来源。但是，是的，我真的在进行一段关于接受那些我无法改变的事情并无论如何都爱自己的旅程。所以我喜欢这个问题。我认为这是我们都应该问自己的一个问题：我们是否达到了100%爱自己的地步？我们还能更爱自己吗？我想我，这两个问题的答案是否和是。我绝对觉得我可以更爱自己。也许我永远不会达到100%，但我老实说，我现在做得挺好的。所以感谢你们所有人的提问。感谢如果你们
gotten this far, that you're still listening. Thank you so much for caring about my little life. It's actually really special. So I really appreciate your time and your attention. If you have an episode suggestion, as always, please feel free to drop me a link at that psychology podcast. I read all and I really do take a lot of inspiration from your ideas. As always, if you also enjoyed this episode, please feel free to leave a five-star review on Apple Podcasts, Spotify, wherever you're listening right now. There's an episode you've loved recently. Share it with a friend. You never know who it will help out. And sincerely, genuinely, deeply, thank you so much for all of your support. Recently, the show has just become this whole new beast, this whole new baby, this whole new
你能走到这一步，说明你还在收听。非常感谢你关心我的小生活。这其实真的很特别。所以我非常感谢你的时间和关注。如果你有关于节目的建议，请随时一如既往地在那个心理学播客给我留言。我都会阅读，并且真的从你们的想法中汲取了很多灵感。一如既往，如果你也喜欢这一集，请随时在 Apple Podcasts、Spotify 或你现在收听的任何地方留下五星好评。如果你最近喜欢某一集，请与朋友分享。你永远不知道它会帮助到谁。真诚地、由衷地、深深地，非常感谢你们所有的支持。最近，这个节目已经变成了一个全新的存在，一个全新的小家伙，一个全新的
project and I just feel so grateful that people connect so much with this content and it is just like I think a point recently where I've really been a point that I've really been reflecting on recently of how lucky I am and how far this community has come so there is not a day that goes by that I don't thank my lucky stars so I appreciate you listening I appreciate you sharing and you following and as always I say as always all the time it's fine we're amongst friends, as always, we will be back on Friday with another episode. So thank you for listening and I will see you then. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. Eighty-four is big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex
项目，我感到非常感激，人们对这些内容有这么深的共鸣，这就像我最近一直在思考的一个问题，我真的一直在反思我有多么幸运，这个社区已经发展到了什么地步，所以没有一天不让我感到无比幸运，所以我感谢你们的收听，感谢你们的分享和关注，就像我总是说的一样，我老是说，没关系，我们都是老朋友了，一如既往，我们将在周五带着另一集回归。所以谢谢你们的收听，我们到时候见。在 Look Back at it 播客中。从 1979 年开始，这对我和说是个大日子。1984 年对我来说意义重大。我是 Sam J.，我是 Alex
English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down and try to make sense of how we survived it with our friends, fellow comedians and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. Before it was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host, Kare Games.
English。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并尝试和我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家一起，理清我们是如何熬过那段时光的。比如 Mark Lamont Hill 谈论 80 年代。在那之前，那是疯狂的一年。那真是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听 Look Back at it。嘿，大家好！欢迎收听 Learn the Hard Way，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人 Kare Games。
This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit are honest? It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the IHard radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Ellen's, correct?
这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都无法真正安全进行的坦诚对话，但你是和一位知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士在交流。有多少男人穿着西装却不够诚实？这向世界发出信号，表明你不是好惹的。仅仅因为你有这个能力，并不意味着你就非得这么做。在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听 Learn the Hard Way。2023 年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的生父。但这次怀孕似乎是一场骗局。埃伦女士，这份特定的检测结果你伪造过两次，对吗？
I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Alesspian. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police.
我伪造过一次检测结果。这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格·阿莱斯皮安。我的脑子炸裂了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这就是《深陷爱河》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。
As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to a Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience
随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听 Love Trapped 播客。2%。这就是在有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析心理韧性、健身以及在
in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side, a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWA% on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an I-Heart podcast.
我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立抗压能力的科学。让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端脱胎换骨，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。名字就是 TWA%，在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方。这是一档 iHeart 播客。
Guaranteed Human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
保证真人。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。